- My name is Zia Sheikh.
I am 35 years old.
I am Chef de Cuisine
at Paowalla Restaurant
and I make 75 thousand a year.
My main responsibilities
as Chef de Cuisine
is to oversee any type
of kitchen operation
from menu development to
dish washing, to working
alongside the cooks, to food labor costs,
sitting down with Chef Floyd for about
10 - 15 minutes a day.
We talk about what's coming
down the line as far as menu.
We are a very highly seasonal restaurant.
We try to use the Union
Square Green Market
as much as possible as
well as local farms.
If it's not in season,
it's not on our menu.
I almost wanna say that
this career chose me.
I dealt with a lot of racism in school
when I was growing up, so I
spent a lot of time at home.
That being said, I spent
a lot of time to myself
and I realized that I
had a love for the arts.
I spent a lot of time with my
mother at home in the kitchen.
So, she actually taught
me how to start cooking
when I was ten years
old, and the first thing
that I made at home was her meatballs.
She was cooking meatballs
for the family and I started
mimicking her moves in
a smaller pot for myself
right next to her and ever since then,
I've fallen in love with cooking.
It was so interesting to me
whereas a year or two later
I started accompanying her to supermarkets
and buying my own produce.
I taught myself how to hold a
knife, how to cut vegetables.
My favorite thing to make
was vegetable stir-fry
just because it involved
about 20 different
vegetables in one dish.
My father passed away when I was 16.
He was always pushing me to
do something with science
and, almost to make him
happy, after he passed away
I enrolled in engineering
school, but then when I got to
engineering school, I
realized that I just didn't
have a passion for it.
That same semester one of
my close friends, Mary,
wanted to do something
nice for her boyfriend
for Valentine's day, so she invited me
and about five other friends
into the kitchen with her
to cook for her boyfriend.
And, between me and these
these five other girls, they were all
impressed that I knew my way around
the kitchen and I almost kinda took over.
After that it was just kinda
staring at me in the face
what I should be doing with my life.
So, I dropped out of college
and went to culinary school.
Now that you're in a
restaurant setting you realize
that everything happens
at a much faster pace
and you're working alongside
more experienced cooks
that can cut faster, that
can cook faster, that can
think faster and basically
the point of the externship
is for you to be immersed
in a new type of world.
My very first job I was making
three hundred dollars a week
and working in a kitchen.
I was doing what I loved
to do, but I didn't
have a lot of money to
spare, so they, my mother
let me still live at home.
It's not ideal for a 23, 24 year old
to be living at home, but at the time,
it was what was necessary to do.
Whatever money I had left
over, whatever money I saved up
to buy cookbooks to keep
reading, to immerse myself
in this world, to take
myself to the next level.
And, I dined out at a lot of restaurants.
I cooked for myself a lot at home, just
testing out new recipes and whatnot.
I did a lot of this at work.
I almost bugged my chefs with
questions about, you know,
can you teach me this,
can you teach me this.
and I started taking
on more and more tasks
to see what I could handle
and what I enjoyed doing.
And, starting out you
will take any job you can
for any amount of money,
for, to learn any part of it.
I used to switch jobs for 50
cents more, if they paid me
and, you know, at the
time I moved around a lot.
I didn't keep a job more
than, for more than 10 months,
and then I went onto
another job after that,
but it was all learning experience.